hey you guys also went through this
weird era of your career where the one
monkey don't stop the show album came
out obviously that was the album that
ceelo was not part of um how hard was it
for you guys to get through some of the
uh bumps in your guys's relationships
you know that
that that you know may or may not have
been public but how i i think
like you know at the end of the day you
guys we're here in 2020
you guys did an album after that but
like that specific just era of your
guys's relationship in the group and at
that point in time i think sealer you're
on your second solo album by then
i think so yeah yeah yeah yeah machine
right
so what what was that area like because
at that time
hey man i'm a fan bro and look at the
the silo green perfect imperfections
that's my
disappoint when you dropped that [ __ ] in
o2 i was like this [ __ ] did not
disappear this is what i wanted from a
cello album it was trippy's crazy
i appreciate that but
you want to take that one come on man
somebody speak on that yeah um
i mean like i said all of us all of us
grew up together
you know what i mean so it wasn't
nothing malicious to wear like [ __ ] when
i see that [ __ ]
it's on on site type [ __ ] so it ain't it
was
it was never like that you know what i
mean so it was just us being
finding another way to communicate you
know what i'm saying with our fans
even though you know what i'm saying we
had we have our little brother with us
you know what i mean
but it was much since i remember seeing
celo
i didn't got them dead marlin one day
you know what i'm saying we was
in a festival somewhere we were just i
was there walking around man and i
forgot what year was that though
you remember when you're there that was
that was uh
that's like oh no that's that's old like
oh
six yeah something like that and when
that one monkey album come out when they
come out
right offo so
we were still working and everything man
i just happened to see ceelo out and got
them a whole nother country man in
denmark man
we was just like like damn man what's up
little brother like man
see y'all man it was instant love man
sorry